November?
More like New-vember...
Neflix-vember...
New-on-Neflix-vember?
Whatever you want to call it, November 2019
is quickly approaching, and Netflix has announced
the movies and TV shows that will be available
to watch throughout the month.
Here's the best stuff hitting Netflix in November
2019.
Netflix subscribers with a love for stand-up
will be treated in a major way, as the streamer
is adding four specials from some of the biggest
names in comedy.
On November 5, tuck into Seth Meyers' stand-up
comedy special Lobby Baby, in which the late-night
host discusses everything from being a father
to the reason why "you should never take your
girlfriend to Paris for her birthday."
Filmed at Minneapolis' Pantages Theater, Seth
Meyers: Lobby Baby is extra-special for two
reasons.
First, it's Meyers' first-ever Netflix comedy
special.
And second, it takes its name from the circumstances
of the birth of his second son, Axel Strahl
Meyers, who came into the world in the lobby
of Meyers' apartment building.
A week later, on November 12, Jeff Garlin:
Our Man in Chicago hits Netflix.
This special is, well, special too.
It was filmed in Garlin's hometown of Chicago
37 years to the day after he debuted as a
stand-up comedian, and it sees the Curb Your
Enthusiasm actor take a stroll down memory
lane that's filled with his, quote, "signature
blend of storytelling and improv."
Iliza Shlesinger's fifth Netflix stand-up
special, Unveiled, will arrive on the platform
on November 19.
Following after 2013's War Paint, 2015's Freezing
Hot, 2016's Confirmed Kills, and 2018's Elder
Millennial, Unveiled sees the recently-married
Shlesinger discuss all things wedding related,
plus the, quote, "dangers of a zombie bachelorette
army."
Finally, on November 26, Mike Birbiglia: The
New One will be available to stream on Netflix.
In his newest stand-up special, Birbiglia
ponders whether he's truly ready to expand
his family and bring a child into the often-terrifying
modern world.
Do you like action franchises, iconic Will
Smith and Martin Lawrence movies from the
'90s, classic Bruce Lee martial arts films,
and sequels?
While we'd say you have quite a specific taste
in cinema, Netflix would say it has you covered.
Coming to Netflix in November 2019 are a handful
of awesome action flicks like 1995's Bad Boys,
featuring Smith and Lawrence as a pair of
Miami detectives looking into the disappearance
of police-seized drugs.
You'll also be able to catch 1973's Enter
the Dragon, the beloved actioner from director
Robert Clouse that marked Lee's final film
role before his death, all three entries in
the Wachowskis' Matrix trilogy, and 2017's
Jumanji: Welcome to the Jungle, a follow-up
to the fantasy-adventure Jumanji from 1995.
Anyone who likes to expand spooky season into
November will be in luck next month on Netflix,
as three extra-eerie flicks are hitting the
streamer.
On the first day of the month, load up Roman
Polanski's seminal psychological horror feature
Rosemary's Baby, starring Mia Farrow as the
titular Rosemary, a pregnant woman who grows
suspicious that a Satanic coven wants to steal
her baby for use in their evil rituals.
"What have you done to it?
What have you done to its eyes?"
On November 4, switch gears to District 9,
the Neill Blomkamp directed sci-fi action-thriller
that takes place in a South African internment
camp known as District 9, where insectoid
aliens that crashed onto Earth have been confined.
A bit later, on November 15, stream Netflix's
original thriller Earthquake Bird, a Tokyo-set
mystery centered around expat Lucy Fly, the
reasons why she's suspected of killing her
missing friend Lily, and the charming photographer
she was romantically involved with.
Escape the drama of your everyday life by
diving into the immersive, already-critically
acclaimed dramas heading to Netflix.
The first arrival, hitting the streamer on
November 1, is The King.
Based on a number of plays from William Shakespeare's
"Henriad" collection, The King tells the story
of a prince who rises to take the English
Throne and become King Henry V, following
the death of his father.
"A king has no friends.
Only followers.
And foe."
The film opened in theaters for a limited
run on October 11, when critics took a liking
to it.
November 27 will see the Netflix debut of
Martin Scorsese's The Irishman, a gangster
epic that chronicles the life and crimes of
Frank "The Irishman" Sheeran, a former mobster
and hitman long presumed to have had a hand
in the disappearance and suspected killing
of Teamster member Jimmy Hoffa.
"Back then, there was nobody in this country
who didn't know who Jimmy Hoffa was."
Like The King, The Irishman will have a limited
theatrical release prior to premiering on
Netflix.
Critics have been praising The Irishman since
it debuted at the New York Film Festival on
September 27, but audiences will have to wait
until November 1 to judge it for themselves,
then hold out a few weeks until it's available
on Netflix.
Those looking for non-Netflix-original dramas
can dig into David Ayer's End of Watch on
November 23, or Ridley Scott's All the Money
in the World on November 30.
Christmas will come early for comedy-lovers
this November.
On the first, Netflix is adding to its content
catalogue a number of hilarious movies like
Step Brothers and Wedding Crashers, the witty
post-apocalyptic flick Zombieland, and even
the subversive black comedy satire Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas.
"Whoa…
These fellas really let themselves go."
Later in the month, Netflix is really rolling
into the holiday spirit.
On November 8, subscribers can stream Let
It Snow.
Based on the New York Times bestseller, the
film follows a group of high school students
as their lives cross paths during a Christmas
Eve snowstorm.
"Snow hides a lot.
It's like the Spanx of weather."
When November 15 rolls around, Netflix will
add animated comedy Klaus to its library,
followed by The Knight Before Christmas on
November 21.
This Vanessa Hudgens-starring flick sees science
teacher Brooke fall for Sir Cole, a medieval
knight transported to the present day by a
mystical sorceress.
Netflix sure didn't forget about TV enthusiasts,
though.
The streamer is bringing a ton of amazing
short-form content to subscribers' screens
in November.
On November 1, you can stream the Netflix
original event American Son, which follows
a mother as she pieces together the disappearance
of her son.
Other stand-out TV additions include the third
season of Atypical and the Queer Eye special
We're in Japan! on November 1.
"I cannot wait to roll up our gorgeous little
gay sleeves and get this ball rolling."
The second season of The End of the F***ing
World and the fourth season of She-Ra and
the Princesses of Power hit the platform on
November 5, while the fifth volume of Patriot
Act with Hasan Minhaj premieres on November
10, and the third season of The Crown a week
later, on November 17.
Netflix also has a few holiday TV specials,
like season 2 of The Great British Baking
Show: Holiday Special on November 8 and season
2 of Nailed It!
Holiday on November 22.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.